[Música]
hay lugares en los que el tiempo parece
no tener agarre y el castillo de
cheverny pertenece a la familia curo
desde hace más de seis siglos la
propiedad sigue siendo habitada por sus
descendientes el marqués de libra y su
mujer y sus hijos
es
y usted
para hacer vivir séverni los
propietarios abrieron al público de
estas cosas de nuestro patrimonio
más de 300.000 visitantes vienen cada
año por su historia y por toda una
variedad de actividades bien orquestadas
incluida la increíble guardería canina
dedicada a la casa de montería cada día
al final de la tarde los carros de
manada esperan con impaciencia su comida
40 kilos de carne de ave y croquetas de
verduras no desafían desde hace media
hora
de las 17 horas en punto lo suelto pero
antes de dejarlos devorar su ración de
comida los adiestradores velan por su
obediencia
d
la lucha está apretada cada perro quiere
su osamenta 400 gramos cada uno
[Aplausos]
vamos
[Música]
fin
llamado clave
el adiestrador que dirige la manada
apila por la equidad entre las partes
la manada debe ser sometida al hombre
respetarlos como dominantes lo que
quieran el dominante pero también que
los teman como tal no hay que dejar
pasar nada todo debe ser justo
[Música]
la actividad de casa de montería en
giverny viene desde 1850 el centenar de
perros recorre hasta 40 kilómetros por
salida en la propiedad o donde algunos
vecinos 70 veces por temporada
para mantener esta tradición acoger a
los turistas y mantener el castillo hay
que trabajar a diario
[Aplausos]
el marqués de vibra y encabeza una
verdadera mediana empresa
en este momento si sumamos los titulares
en los temporales y los estudiantes hay
más de 60 personas
y para atraer cada vez más turistas el
marqués transformó este naranjal del
siglo 18 en restaurante
sonata de visita muy difícil es
suficientes visitantes no tendremos
recursos para mantener este monumento es
que la educación es a cielo
[Aplausos]
las obras de mantenimiento de severn y
le cuestan cada año 200 mil euros a la
familia una suma importante para esta
propiedad que no recibe subsidio del
estado el marqués debe innovar
permanentemente
y padre hizo pasar a cheverny una etapa
profesional en términos de frecuentación
y sale el turismo con grecia un golf en
generación red el parque de hogar dimos
también el alojamiento cada generación
aporta su grano de arena son jardines
su más reciente creación es la
exposición tintín en un anexo del
castillo de bernie el modelo de erc para
dibujar moulinsart la morada del famoso
capitán haddock
un visitante de cada tres viene hace
bernie por el universo tintín
una palanca turística y sobre todo
económica
30 de la facturación de la tienda es más
grande
con los tickets de ingreso tintín le
genera más de 600.000 euros a los
propietarios cada año
los visitantes también vienen hacia
bernie para descubrir el universo
suntuoso en el que la familia
aristocrática vive desde hace siglos
algunos espacios del castillo poner en
escena la intimidad de la pareja
entonces aquí está la habitación de los
cónyuges con el vestido de la marquesa
de delante entonces la actual marquesa
que se casó en 1994 hemos visto el
vestido de matrimonio y nosotros
preguntamos también un poco del niño
pero bueno ellos seguir así en sus
misivas horas agradable verlo para
entrar donde ellos los propietarios
toman el mismo camino que los visitantes
la pareja vive en el ala derecha del
castillo
sin duda es un museo con su historia sus
riquezas y sus problemas el hecho de
vivir en su lugar de trabajo es una gran
instante es una elección porque
consideramos que era una oportunidad
era poner la suerte de nuestro lado para
que nuestros hijos nunca tengan ganas de
irse así que madeleine de proust
intervenga un día y diga no a estas
escaleras que las recuerdas me recuerda
hasta el momento etcétera
si no podemos venderlo no es posible
[Música]
por el tiempo llegaron y se volvió una
empresa familiar próspera que genera
cada año más menos 4 millones de euros
de facturación es el segundo castillo de
la lugar más frecuentado justo detrás de
hanvon
[Música]